Monday was a day off for most people but
not for Peter King football morning in
America what you need to know on this
Tuesday begins with some Nuggets that he
harvested from NFL executive VP of
football operations Troy Vincent there
are votes coming up later this week on a
couple of potential rules proposals that
have not yet been voted on because the
owners have not been able to get
together in the store not getting
together it's a virtual meeting for
these potential rule changes and one of
the big questions is now that replay
review for pass interference calls and
non calls is going away what will they
replace it with before we move on to
what they were place it with though Troy
Vincent the executive VP of football
operations acknowledged that last year's
pass interference replay rule was a
disaster what we put in last year those
outcomes were not good for professional
football we failed
I'm first in line I shared that with
League officials I failed as the leader
of that department what did we learn
from that
we've got to do our due diligence you
can't rush and just shove something in
there without knowing all the
consequences and we found that out last
year live in an action publicly we
didn't do our due diligence last year
and we failed and we failed miserably
let me tell you something I appreciate
the candor but I'm the commissioner if
I'm the commissioner and I see that I I
expect the last line of that quote to be
I therefore resigned from my job I mean
certain certain screw-ups are big enough
that when you say I've just hey man I
don't know what I'm doing I mean it's
and look I got a lot of respect for
Vincent again I respect the candor but
there's a line where your candor walks
you right out the door
well okay yes I get it I I more
appreciate the candor and the
truthfulness though than anything and
you know it wasn't like this destroyed
Vincent's like idea to make sure that
this happened I mean this was thrusted
down his throat to Mike by the NFL the
fans the media everybody so he tried to
make it make it work as best as possible
and I understand he deserves some of the
blame there because yeah of course he's
in charge of a lot of what's being done
but but at the same time this this is a
league wide issue this is not a Troy
Vincent issue you know this is across
the
bored and you know that I was against
this from the get-go I mean I can
remember a show with you you know you I
you me and big cat on here not long
after the Superbowl in which the
Patriots beat the Rams where we were
going I don't want to see this rule at
one time we saw it in the history of our
football where there was such a blunder
call that it affected a big moment in
the history of the sport yes I get it
but it was the disaster last year and
he's truthful there it was stunk it
ruined football games there was a lot of
bad calls and ruin for some seasons for
some teams and how they got off the you
know we saw just two plays right there
it affected teams losing games in that
Texas game and and of course the New
York Giants versus the Patriots ruining
seasons is a little bit strong though
yeah it might be strong I agree you're
right season was ruined all right you
can set that point I didn't want this I
wanted sky judge I thought something
needed to be done and sky judge is the
fix it continues to be the ideal fix
we'll talk about that in a second let's
put this to bed first Chris because one
thing that there is disagreement on even
within the competition committee is
whether this was a failure from the
get-go a failure of concept or a failure
of execution and you could argue this is
never going to work because you are
invading the inherently subjective
decision-making that comes from
determining what is and what isn't pass
interference now look I believe that
there are certain plays that are so
clearly on the right side of the line
where you say that's definitely pass
interference they should have dropped a
flag we have to drop a flag the problem
is you get closer to the line where do
you differentiate and that's what they
struggled with last year so it was maybe
Park concept part execution because what
did we witness all year long the bar
kept moving we thought right here then
it moves down then it moves up then it
moves down and constantly I was hearing
that our River on who has taken way too
much blame for this and there's still
people who want to blame our River on
for it you need to understand there are
people above him that were telling him
what to do and how to do it
this isn't just his call and
so when you have in real time the
urgency of making the decisions and your
bosses are moving the bar on you all the
time and they're mad about whatever
decision you make you make the decision
they're mad at you you you're being too
stringent all right you drop it or
you're not being stringent enough then
you move it and it was it was a mess so
it was a combination of a bad concept
and also poor execution because of the
pressure and the misdirection that those
above our Veron continued to place on
him all year long well yeah and I think
that's exactly what Troy Vincent is
talking about the unforeseen
consequences and those type of things
everything rushed it was that rush to
did it into judgment there with this
conversation and yet things were not
well thought out and so not well thought
out to what you're saying Mike I mean it
went from okay where it's gotta be so
egregious we'll never overturn it and
then it became okay now we're gonna call
it to the letter of the law and then
also to went back to it's got to be so
egregious that's the only way we're
gonna overturn it and of course it hurts
some teams you know and I know when I
misspoke before you know I say that it
messed up some seasons well it certainly
altered some games and that affected
team seasons that way but it was just a
disaster altogether
first off none of us people like you and
I am Tony Dungy and Rodney Ayers in the
Mike Tirico but watching football our
whole lives Rodney Harrison a borderline
Hall of Famer Tony Dungy in the Hall of
Fame I mean we listen to them on a
weekly basis argue about was that
bastard appearance was it not we don't
know what the hell they're gonna call
the New York you know so it became a
talking point to a negative talking
point during the hundredth anniversary
of the NFL season that's where it was
just all bad let alone if we're trying
to get young viewers into this sport we
can't be having 10-minute delays to
watch the referees huddle up and figure
out whether it's pass interference and
all that crap either so I'm glad they're
done with it the problem is that the
shifting standard affects the integrity
of a season and we hear like that all
the time in other contexts and in this
setting specifically having a rule that
was applied differently throughout the
course of the season does affect the
integrity of the 256 regular season
games the good
News is by the time we got to the
postseason it seemed to be under control
there wasn't any major controversy in
any of the 11 postseason games but Chris
look even though it's it's hard to
pinpoint how it may have affected
someone's season surely you take out
that one play and you flip it if it was
called if it wasn't called if it should
have been called if it shouldn't have
been called it can't affect a game it
can affect the outcome of one game which
can have a cascading effect on a regular
season that's why you want the same rule
to be in place the same standard right
so so with that dead the question is
what will they replace it with and there
is momentum building for the sky judge
concept even though they don't apply
that term they call it the booth umpire
or the senior technical advisor to the
referee or something like that the
assistant to the regional manager some
complicated convoluted term there are
concerns though about their ability to
find 17 people who would be properly
skilled and trained and suited to serve
in that capacity and this is how I'm
always going to explain it because I
think this is critical for the NFL to
have it that person that bridges the gap
between what the officials see on the
field and what we see at home someone
who knows the rules someone who has
experience on the field and someone who
can sit there and watch all the camera
angles and help the folks on the field
when they miss things because they
inevitably do Troy Vincent says the
concept of the eighth man in the boot
has some booth has some merit but we
just don't have the pipeline of
officials today can we get there yes but
today it could be a challenge to make a
Lee a former referee who would be a
prime candidate for the I think they
could find 17 former referees they
really want to do it
fingers together here not to simulate
cricket wings but to say pay the money
and you'll find 17 people Tyree McCauley
says finding 17 who have the skills to
do the job and then clearly defining
which rules can be enforced and which
rules can't be enforced is extremely
problematic until there's a consensus on
both of those issues it would be
difficult to imagine how this could be
successfully implemented I don't
disagree with that
step one pay the people if you have the
money if you show up and having the
money shows the motivation to do this
Chris that's right excuse making this is
excuse making at the highest level I'm
not blaming Terry for it tarries
reflecting the move that he is detecting
from the people who are involved they
don't want to pay for it so when you
don't want to pay for it you use excuses
like oh well hohoho rump for rump with
we're gonna have a hard time building
the pipeline you're not gonna have a
hard time building the pipeline if you
decide you're gonna pay seven figures
for that job I guarantee you that and
can you afford it you damn can so go get
Terry McCauley gene starett or Mike
Pereira Dean Blandino Ed Hochuli anybody
who has retired from a referee job over
the past five years
you got your 17 you pay him a million
each and you're good to go now well we
pay we don't pay that much the referees
well look that's your problem because
the most important function on field
during the 256 regular season games you
maybe need to devote more money to these
positions so guys don't jump to networks
where they get greedy for less pressure
and less work and less scrutiny and less
everything more money unless everything
is a good deal so you have to compete
with that it's not hard to do you got
the money to do it it's that simple
Chris I'll show them no it's that simple
I mean more money to the referees in
general just to where we have more
referees that want to be or more
qualified people who want to be referees
to refresh that pipeline that Troy
Vincent's talking about you know that's
the big issue - I mean you're right I
think a lot of people who you know used
to flirt with the idea of I want to be
arrests this day and age now with
Twitter and social media and oh I could
have 17 great games and mess up one
little call in the first quarter of a
wild card playoff game you know and
people want to you know kill that ref
and murder them I mean it's really
gotten that crucial to where I think a
lot of these guys look at it go damn
what the hell live for that pay for what
they're paying I don't want to deal with
all that and the scrutiny and everything
that goes along with it so you know
really it's probably a fundamental
problem and just paying the referees
more in general to get more people to
want that job and then you're right Mike
I mean at the end of the day for the
sky' job sky judge and all those things
yeah the gene starett tours all them
certainly you're gonna have to pray a
pay a pretty penny too
them away from the networks but also
yeah anybody that's a retired referee
that we think okay has gotten out of the
he doesn't want to move on the field
anymore he's out of that age he can't do
that stuff get him in the sky job you
know sky judge position anybody with
experience can help in this situation
here's how I interpret the comments from
Troy Vincent and the comments from Terry
McCauley what's going to happen this
week is that they will adopt sky judge
on an experimental basis for the
preseason if there is one that's it and
until they can have a year or two of
data from experimenting with sky judge
in the preseason the problem is who's
yeah it's gonna be hard to do the right
experiment if you don't the best
possible people in the job right if you
got some schlub that doesn't know what
he or she is doing who is talking to the
referee during the game and distracting
and irritating the referee because this
person doesn't understand the rules
thoroughly enough doesn't have the
experience on the field doesn't have the
authority to speak to the referee and
say drop a flag pick up a flag move the
ball whatever it's never gonna work see
the question is do they want this to
work if they want it to work they will
direct the money to it and they have the
money to do it they'll direct the
funding to it and they will get the best
people but I think they're trying to set
this up as a preseason experiment we've
seen that before with the potential rule
changes and if it ever gets passed it'll
be passed on a one-year basis just like
the replay review standard was so that
you would need 24 votes to renew it the
next year not twenty two four votes to
kill it once it becomes a permanent rule
change but I think this is several years
away from happening and here's what will
happen here's what I think they're gonna
try to do they're gonna try to kick the
can with the old rules for a while to
see if the D outcry for something beyond
the seven officials on the field is
mandated by whether it's people who are
losing money on bad calls via so I think
they may try to kick the can for a
little bit until they realize we have no
choice we've got to spend the money to
staff this position and use it well
that's where I was gonna ask you for you
know when does you know legalized
gambling come into the conversation here
I mean again it's going to be a such a
big part of the sport
a team in Las Vegas there's gonna be
billions and billions of dollars into
the league you know this would be an
investment I would think the league
wants to make just to you know soothe Oh
soothe over consumers and betters out
there to make them feel good okay the
NFL is doing everything they can to make
this game fair and officiated the right
way and they have the right protocols
and people you know in the sky judge
position or whatever that may be I would
think that's a big part of it in the
NFL's gonna have to balance that out
over the next year or two here's the
reality when the dust settles on the
pandemic and states decide to try to
rebuild the budgets that have been
busted by what's happened shrinking tax
base etcetera increased costs public
services the easy way for states to make
back the money that they lost during the
pandemic is to legalize two things Cris
legalized gambling and marijuana and I
think we're gonna see both of them sweep
the country anybody that was on the
fence or against it I know you're very
happy to hear that
legalized for recreational purposes in
far more States than it currently is and
gambling will be legalized the states
that were reluctant to do it will
embrace it because that is the easy way
you tax the hell out of the marijuana
and the gambling and you make back a lot
of that money but the thing is yeah as
more and more people are wagering their
hard-earned money on sports the outcomes
need to be more pure the calls can't be
egregiously bad and the obligation will
be on the NFL to make it right and to
spend the money to make it right it's
easy to justify spending the money
because they're gonna make more money
generally and specifically off of the
proliferation of legalized gambling
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports